j'ouvre notre second débat consacré aux
élections américaines avec cette
question Donald Trump est-il sur une
voie royale d'un retour à la maison
blanche il a encore des embuches
notamment judiciaire et un président
sortant affrontter accessoirement mais
après sa large victoire dans le cocus de
l'owa le candidat milliardaire conforte
son statut de favori chez les
républicains Hugo
lemogier une victoire sans surprise pour
l'exprésident américain Donald Trump
remporte le
avec 51% des
suffrages nous voulons remercier le
grand peuple de l'a nous vous aimons
tous quelle participation
foule galvanis par la dynamique de leur
champion les partisans de Donald Trump
le VO déjà rempter l'investiture
américaine et retourner à la maison
blanche il a prisel je pense qu'il va h
écrasereses
primaires préends républain jette
l'éponge les uns après les autres le
dernier en dat l'entrepreneur Vivec
ramaswani a fait allégance à Donald
Trump Donald Trump doit être notre
candidat r Santis et nikal rendrait
service à ce pays en retirant leur
candidature pour que nous nous
concentrions sur la nomination de Donald
Trump et que nous retrouvions notre pays
arrivé deè dans l'owa avec 21 % des voix
l'ultra conservateur Ron Detis dégringol
dans les sondages mais continue de
croire en ses
chances grâce à votre soutien malgré
tout ce que les médias nous ont lancé
tout ce qui était contre nous nous avons
réussi à nous en sortir dans
l'a seule femme dans la course Nicki
l'ancienne ambassaderce des États-Unis à
l'ONU sous Donald Trump espère marquer
des points dans la prochaine étape de la
campagne l'état du
nuancheur notre campagne est le dernier
espoir d'arrêter le cauchemar Trump
Biden
je t'aime aowa mais nous passons au New
Hampshire la primaire du New Hampshire
aura lieu le 23 janvier prochain un
scrutin qui devrait donner le ton pour
le reste de la campagne avant le point
d'org des investitures américaines le 5
mars le Super Tuesday où 14 États
éliront leurs candidats le train
électoral de Donald Trump est lancé vers
la Maison Blanche qu'est-ce qui pourrait
le faire dérailler on en débat avec
elisachelle bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes professeur de sciences Politi
à l'Université Paris nanire et
rédactrice en chef de la revue politique
américaine Alexis Pichard bonsoir et
bienvenue chercheur en civilisation
américaine Anne Loren Bujon bonsoir et
bienvenue bonsoir vous êtes directrice
de la revue Esprit et chercheuse associé
au programme Amérique du Nord de l'IFRI
l'Institut français des relations
internationales on est également en
luplexe avec Olivier pyon avocat au
barreau de Washington bonsoir lier pyon
auteur de camala Haris la pionnière de
l'Amérique publiée chez plomb et Mathieu
croissand évidemment est rester à mes
côtés euh éditorialiste politique je
rappelle on l'a vu mais rapidement le
cette victoire sans appel dans dans
l'aioa Trump 51 % Ron deantis un peu
plus de 21 % nckial un peu plus de 19 %
30 points d'avance elisachelle est-ce
qu'on peut pour autant parler d'un
triomphe pour Donald Trump si on rentre
un peu dans le dans le détail de
l'analyse alors effectivement Donald
Trump a 30 points d'avance sur Ron
deantis mais il faut se souvenir qu'il
avait remporté en 2020 cet Étap avec 97
% des voix les conditions étaient certes
différentes il était président sortant
il n'avait qu'un seul concurrent mais là
on est dans une situation qui est plus
mitigée qu'elle n'y paraît parce que on
s'attendait à dans un état qui est quand
même majoritairement blanc rural
conservateur évangélique a un score
beaucoup plus important et là 51 % ça
veut dire que dans ce qui devrait être
normalement sa base électorale vraiment
son socle il y a euh presque un électeur
sur deux qui ne soutient pas Donald
Trump euh donc ça veut dire que certes
il gagne c'est une victoire indéniable
mais euh ce n'est pas une victoire
écrasante
euh contrairement à ce qu'on aurait pu
s'attendre ou à ce qu'on peut lire ici
et là il il y a pas eu une participation
très importante Alexis Pichard faut dire
qu'il visisait un temps il y avait un
blizard enfin bon fallait vraiment
braver le le grand froid pour aller euh
pour aller voter qui sont ces électeurs
justement qui sont allés pour voter
Trump c'est quoi sa base électorale euh
la base électorale de Trump comme ça a
été dit très bien et très justement ce
sont plutôt des électeurs ruraux des
électeurs blancs des électeurs hommes
d'un certain âge donc de plus de 50 ans
euh très conservateur sur des valeurs à
la fois des valeurs morales mais aussi
économiquement hein ce sont des gens qui
qui prennent le protectionnisme euh et
ce sont des gens qui sont euh comment
dire qui ont été inféodés à Trump qui
sont devenus des des membres d'une secte
qui serait le trumpisme et d'ailleurs
Donald Trump leur a dit même si vous
deviez mourir à l'issue de de ce vote il
faut aller voter même si vous pouvez
mourir de foid en allant voter donc
voilà c'est cette c'est cet électorat
qui est al qui est évangéliste c'està
dire qui qui a une aussi une ferveur une
ferveur protestante qui est très forte
mais qui a aussi une ferveur trumpiste
donc ils ont un double culte et qui qui
d'ailleurs se rejoignne parce que Donald
Trump est se pose comme une sorte de
Messi selon certainesé on y reviendra on
regardera une vidéo ensemble qui est
complètement aurissante un peu de
pédagogie si vous voulez bien c'est quoi
un cocus alors oui faut toujours
rappeler que les élections primaires
c'est pas l'élection générale c'est pas
les mêmes électeurs donc qu'elles sont
organisées État par État selon des
règles qui diffèrent d'un état à l'autre
donc il y a d'abord des cocus et des
primaires le cocus c'est une assemblée
délibérative donc ici je crois qu'il y
en avait 1700 dans l'aiowa donc il faut
imaginer 1700 groupes d'électeurs
républicains qui se rassemblent pour
quelques heures dans un gymnase dans une
mairie voilà ou autre et qui écoute euh
les les et qui écoute en fait les
partisans des différents candidats leur
présenter leur qualités et qui à l'issue
d'une d'une délibération d'une
discussion d'un débat en choisisse un en
votant ou c'est pas à main levée quand
même c'est c'est une forme de vote alors
je je pense que ça dépend des cocus ça
dépend des États mais ce qu'il faut bien
retenir c'est que 1700 fois on demande à
un petit groupe de choisir un candidat
et qu'ici Trump a quand même remporté je
crois 98 des 99 comptés de laa c'est
quand même une victoire Franch et
massive ou est-ce que du coup on peut
imaginer qu' a une forme de pression
psychologique je vu que c'est une
assemblée délibérative on sait qu' la
prime aux grandes gueule aux gens qui
s'expriment bien peut-être ce qu'on on
un tempérament un peu plus mécianique
que d'autres et que le résultat pourrait
être différent dans un système de
primaire plus classique ù où on vote à
bultin secret ou pas alors je pense que
la différence d'un état à l'autre c'est
quand même surtout une différence de
sociologie électorale comme on nous a
dit là et que et que l'owa c'est un état
très blanc très chrétien et que dans le
New Hampshire par ex exemple qui va être
la prochaine échéance on va trouver des
électeurs aussi plus modérés et donc
peut-être plus d'électeurs favorable à
Nicky
hay le cocus si vous voulez c'est un peu
ça fait partie du folklore électoral
américain c'est ça pass pas comme ça
dans tous les états après il y a un
système de vote beaucoup plus classique
oui oui non c'est quelques États qui
procèdent par cocus de même que dans les
États qui procèdent par primaire la
primaire peut être ouverte semi-ouverte
ou fermée selon qu'on ouvre aux
électeurs du parti d'en face
mais on pourrait dire du cocus quand
même que l'idée c'est de revenir à une
forme de de démocratie
délibérative originel donc des pressions
des groupes d'intérêts il y en a
toujours mais après pouvoir organiser un
débat en temps direct ça a quelque chose
d'atttrayant aussi une primaire
évidemment ça coûte
cherachel est-ce que Ron De Santis et
Nick ont les moyens d'aller jusqu'au
bout est-ce qu'ils ont suffisamment
d'argent parce que c'est aussi ça les
élections aux États-Unis et bien le leur
score successifs aux différentes
primaires vont aussi encourager les
donateurs c'est-à-dire que les les
donations ne sont sont pas terminées
effectivement le coût des campagne
électorale connaî une inflation très
très importante aux États-Unis on a vu
que ça a coûté cher à Vivec ramwami par
exemple qui s'est
retiré lundi soir suite à à
euh la on va dire la courte avance
malgré tout de Trump
et suite à au fait qu'il voulait euh se
mettre comme se placer comme le candidat
qui défend Donald Trump donc euh lui qui
est un candidat autofinancé a bien euh
réalisé que ça lui coûtait assez cher et
que si il voulait être du côté de Trump
la meilleure place c'était c'était de se
retirer donc ça peut être effectivement
un critère qui peut limiter euh la
campagne ça les ça ne les empêche pas de
se présenter mais ça les obligera à
faire des choix en terme de campagne de
nombre de meeting de déplacement parce
que tout ça a un coup et euh évidemment
l'argent est un critère de sélection
dans les campagnes américaines alors ça
ça ne devrait pas poser de souci à à
Donald Trump à priori on cherche dans ce
débat à voir ce qui pourrait faire
dérailler le le train électoral de
Donald
Trump on on parlera des affaires
judiciaires dans un instant on va y
consacrer un un vrai chapitre évidemment
mais Olivier piton je me tourne vers
vous une première fois à Washington
est-ce que un accord
entre rond de Santis et Nicky pour
contrer Donald Trump c'est de la
politique fiction est-ce que ça vous
semble totalement improbable ça par
exemple bah ça devient beaucoup plus
compliqué depuis le cocus de l'ayowa
parce que c'était l'un l'un des souhaits
des des de la partie antitrump parmi les
républicains il faut bien comprendre que
ce cocus c'est une triple victoire et
clairement une triple victoire pour
Donald Trump d'abord parce qu'il fait
plus en terme de voix que l'ensemble de
ses adversaires réunis deuxièmement il
faut pas l'oublier c'est que il est si
ça a été rappelé il est en tête dans
tous les comptés l'exception d'un seul
dans lequel il est juste d'une voix
derrière ni quialet troisièmement ça
c'est on parlait d'un air de la guerre
de l'argent c'est très important il n'a
pratiquement pas dépensé d'argent lors
du cocus de l'Iowa tout simplement parce
que les la plupart des médias ont fait
on parlera de de la de la chronique
judiciaire dans un moment a fait le
travail pour lui et donc il a dépensé
comparativement beaucoup moins d'argent
que rond de Santis qui lui a misé
énormément sur le cocus de l'ayowa et
même de nckialet donc il conserve sont
trésor de guerre et puis quatrièmement
pour répondre clairement à votre
question la mauvaise nouvelle en prime
c'est que d'une certaine manière les
deux candidats qui
pouvaient rassembler les antirtrump du
parti républicain c'est-à-dire nickial
et Ron De Santis se neutralise sail si
vous voulez r De Santis fait 21 %
nckiale fait 19 % la chance ou l'espoir
aurait été que l'un des deux prenne
considérablement de l'avance sur l'autre
de sorte que d'une certaine manière il
rassemble autour aour de lui ou autour
d'elle ceux qui souhaitaient s'opposer à
Donald Trump donc en prime Donald Trump
peut s'offrir le luxe d'avoir ces deux
principaux adversaires qui sont au même
niveau qui conservent donc toutes leurs
chance de continuer le la campagne au
moins sans doute jusqu'au supertus d du
5 mars et qu'en l'occurrence clairement
le le front antirtrump au sein du parti
républicain est toujours aussi fracturé
Alexis Pichard y a des débats télévisés
qui sont prévus dans les dans les
prochains jours alors est-ce que Trump
va enfin y participer parce que jusqu'à
présent il les a snobbé alors le dernier
qui devait avoir lieu au sein des
primaires dans le cas des primaires
républicaines a été annulé je crois
aujourd'hui ou
hier donc Donald Trump n'avait pas prévu
d'y participer comme c'est le cas pour
tous les débats qui ont eu lieu ici
pourquoi parce que il avait tout à y
perdre tout à perdre en fait à
participer à ce à ces ces débats dans au
sens où il aurait été la site de toutes
les attaques et il a préféré surplomber
l'événement et se placer en candidat
Natur du parti il il a enjambé
finalement cette cette cette primaire il
a déjà eu il a déjà tenu lors de sa
victoire dans l'aiowa un discours qui
est présidentiable au sens où il a dit
maintenant il est temps de se rassembler
et j'appelle les démocrates à venir
aussi derrière moi donc il il engemre
complètement acté le fait qu'il a gagné
sur les débats ou non je suis d'accord
avec une grande partie de cette analyse
en fait Donald Trump effectivement
essaie d'accélérer le calendrier pour
être déjà dans une position d'être le
seul candidat investi par le Parti
républicain face à Joe Biden mais enfin
il peut pas quand même complètement le
faire et c'est vrai que la façon dont il
a snobbé les débats comme si les autres
n'étaient pas dignes de discuter avec
lui mais parce qu'il avait toute cette
attention médiatique à la sortie des
différents tribunaux où il est convoqué
je pense que c'est un problème déjà en
terme de démocratie juste ce que
j'entends jusqu'ici avec lequel je suis
pas totalement d'accord c'est la notion
de de candidat antitrump si je crois
qu'il faut vraiment distinguer Ron Detis
et Nicki hay rô de STIs il se présente
comme une sorte de Trump mais en plus
présentable c'est le gendre idéal mais
il essaie de dire qu'il est Maga et donc
son problème à lui c'est que les gens
risquent de préférer America green donc
risquent de préférer l'original à la
copie mais on peut vraiment pas le
décrire comme un candidat antitrump hein
il fait campagne sur la question des
guerres culturelles et et là non mais ce
que disait Olivier Pitton en tout cas ce
que j'ai compris c'est que les antitrump
au sein du parti républicain espéraent
que l' des deux dé pour pouir alors
juste pour préciser que en fait les
antitrump sont très peu nombreux au sein
du parti républicain aujourd'hui donc ce
que tout ça confirme si vous voulez
c'est aussi le point auquel Donald Trump
a complètement capturé le parti
républicain et donc il reste une poignée
de gens qui aimeraiit mieux quelqu'un
d'autre que Trump et puis une poignée de
gens qui vraiment le détestent les les
never trumpers mais c'est une petite
minorité et donc même nickii qui se
présente plus en opposition à Trump que
Ron Detis elle fait attention de pas
l'attaquer trop trop frontalement non
plus alors on va parler évidemment des
affaires judiciaires puisqueon se pose
la question des obstacles qui se
dressent sur la route de Donald Trump
plusieurs accusations et notamment des
accusations de fraude fiscal et banqua
on va écouter la procureur générale de
l'État de New
York en fin de compte le message est
simple peu importe le pouvoir ou la
richesse personne n'est au-dessus de la
loi et la loi s'applique à nous tous de
manière égale et équitable je suis
persuadée que la justice sera rendue et
j'ai confiance en cela et je suis
extrêmement fier du procès que nous
avons mené et on va faire en quelque
sorte la la liste des affaires
judiciaires qui menacent Donald Trump
avec Marion Vig heureux bonsoir Marion
dès dès dès hier après sa victoire dans
l'Iowa il était de retour devant la
justice effectivement au tribunal civil
de New York pour un procès en
diffamation inenté par une écrivaine qui
l'a déjà fait condamné pour agression
sexuelle en tout le candidat républicain
est visé par au moins six procès civils
et pénal et ce sont les quatre procès au
pénal qui sont les plus important
impactant pardon pour lui et pour
lesquels évidemment il plaît non
coupable il y a tout d'abord le plus
grave d'entre eux celui qui concerne son
rôle lors de l'attaque du Capitol le 6
janvier 2021 le procès est prévu le 4
mars mais le calendrier pourrait évoluer
puisqueen ce moment la Cour d'appel
fédérale de Washington examine sa
demande d'immunité pénale en tant
qu'ex-président et puis parce que que le
8 février prochain il y a aussi la Cour
suprême c'est la plus haute juridiction
américaine qui examinera les décisions
des états du Colorado et duumain de
rendre inéligible Donald Trump du fait
de son implication dans l'insurrection
on rappelle que cette cour elle est à
majorité républicaine avec six juges
républicains et trois juges démocrates
ce qui veut dire qu'il y aura forcément
un impact dans leur décision évidemment
autre procès important majeur pour le le
candidat cette tentative de modifier le
résultat de l'élection présidentielle de
2020 dans l'état de geéorgie alors aux
dernièrees nouvelle le procès pourrait
avoir lieu en août 2024 pour éviter de
de le chevauchement avec d'autres procès
Trump comparé avec 18 autres prévenus il
est accusé donc de manipulation pour
inverser les résultats de l'élection
autre affaire celle des documents
classifiés retrouvés dans ses résidences
privées l'audience a été fixée au 25 mai
2024 ce qui se joue ici ce n'est pas
tant le fait qu'il a détenu des
documents mais qu'il a fait obstruction
à la justice en refus de les restituer
et puis dernier de ces quatre procès
celui qui l'oppose à stormy Daniel oui
une actrice porno dont il a acheté le
silence avant l'élection présidentielle
de 2016 en falsifiant les comptes d'une
de ces sociétés pour lui verser de
l'argent le procès est prévu le 25 mars
2024 à noter que dans tous ces procès on
ne s'attend pas à des réponses de la
justice avant au moins le mois de
novembre sans compter qu'ensuite il y
aura des recours possibles et c'est très
compliqué de savoir comment les choses
vont donc évoluer pour Donald Trump
puisqu'il n'y a pas de de précédent dans
l'histoire des États-Unis jamais un
candidat à la présidentielle n'a eu à
faire face à autant d'affaires
judiciaires merci beaucoup Marion
Vigreux Ellis Chelle est-ce qu'il y a
encore on parlait de de de la petite
partie de l'électorat républicain qui
est peut-être ent Trump est-ce qu'il y a
une partie de cet électorat modéré sur
qui c'est cette multiplication
d'affaires peut avoir un effet
hésitation à voter pour Donald Trump oui
tout à fait 38 % de l'électorat
américain n'est pas affilié parti donc
oui donc là c'est on parle pas des
républicains on parle de de tout
l'électorat américain exactement donc on
ne sait pas où ces électeurs vont aller
et c'est un facteur déterminant dans ces
dans ces élections et effectivement le
fait que cet ancien président soit
chargé de tant de dossiers judiciaires
et est un handicap c'est c'est très
clair mais c'est aussi un handicap pour
Donald Trump on parlait tout à l'heure
de sa participation au débat bien sûr
qu'il ne veut il n'a que des cou prendre
dans ce type de débat mais il a aussi un
calendrier judiciaire particulièrement
chargé s qu'il y il y était aujourd'hui
là à l'audience on parlait on a parl
avec Marion donc il participe à la
médiatisation de ces procès il considère
que ça lui réussit bien sûr mais au-delà
de de la partie médiatique est visible
il y a toute la préparation des dossiers
avec les avocats les différents
rendez-vous qui ne sont pas les
audiences formelles donc ça prend quand
même énormément de temps en plus de
prendre de l'argent donc il essae certes
de faire nécessiter vertu en médiatisant
une partie de ces de ces passages mais
beaucoup moins que l'année dernière si
vous vous souvenez l'année dernière on
voyait des hélicoptères filmer Donald
Trump sortant de chez lui allant dans
son avion traversant les États-Unis dans
son jet privé enfin c'était une
véritable saga médiatique aujourd'hui
c'est encore médiatisé mais pas au même
niveau que l'année dernière mais est-ce
qu' l'inverse ça sert pas son récit même
puisque c'est le candidat antiystème
victime d'un empêchement judiciaire des
élites d'un complot tout tout
laaccumulation de ces procès le dessert
ou le sert au final son propre je pense
qu'il y a une double réponse alors
effectivement les affaires judiciaires
font les affaires politiques et même
financières de Donald Trump puisque par
exemple la photo du mshot qui a été
prise lorsqu'il a été interpellé par la
police c'était en en août dernier donc
c'est c'est photo d'identification
judiciireort judiciire a été ensuite
fait a fait l'objet de produit dérivés
qui lui a rapporté qui lui a rapporté
pardon 7 millions de dollars qu'il a
investi du coup dans sa campagne et sur
le récit effectivement Donald Trump
c'est le récit de l'homme d'affaires
venu du peuple persécuté par le système
persécuté par la politique enfin par la
justice qu' estime politisé et à la seld
du gouvernement démocrate de Joe Biden
donc naturellement auprès de son de son
électorat qui qui adore ça qui qui aime
être galvanisé par ce r grand récit du
candidat qui est persécuté ça marche et
ça marche par contre ça marche
uniquement pour ses électeurs comme le
disait ma collègu auprès des des des
autres électeurs qui sont pas des
trumpistes euh ce récit peut avoir en
tout cas cette C cet enchaînement des
affaires peut avoir un effet repoussoir
et les les les dissociés finalement de
la de la candidature de Trump oui donc
si si je comprends bienineon ça peut le
renforcer pour l'investisure
républicaine mais peut-être un peu le
fragiliser ensuite dans ce face à face
annoncé face à Joe Biden il y a beaucoup
de questions en fait il y a beaucoup
d'incertitude sur la façon dont ça peut
jouer jusqu'ici il arrive vraiment à
retourner cette attention médiatique a
son avantage elle sert son récit il est
victime d'une chasse aux sorcières les
élites sont ompu on ne peut pas compter
sur les institutions il se prépare
d'ailleurs à faire s'il était élu un
très grand ménage en se vengeant de
toutes les personnes qui ont cherché à
lui nuire ou à lui faire du tort et je
pense qu'il faut écouter soigneusement
ce qu'il dit à cet égard parce que par
le passé il a déjà fait ce qu'il avait
annoncé mais dans un deuxième temps
quand on en sera à l'élection général et
où son euh son son adversaire cette
fois-ci sera bien JO Biden ça pourrait
le desservir mais il y a beaucoup de il
y a beaucoup d'incertitude et pour les
juges qui les différents juges donc
c'est effectivement un tel embrouillam
mini de poursuite judiciaire qu'il faut
essayer de s'y retrouver entre le niveau
fédéral le niveau étatique les affaires
privées les affaires de de de de
falsification de comptees et et la
question de l'assaut du Capitol et des
tentativ de manipulation de résultats
électoraux donc il y a beaucoup de
choses différentes et pour les juges il
faut essayer de trouver le juste milieu
entre le fait de rendre des décisions
qui semblent neutres et impartiales en
respectant le
calendrier et et et tout en tenant
compte du du contexte politique qui est
évidemment complètement inflammatoire
donc ça va dépendre aussi de la
perception qu'auront les Américains de
la manière dont la justice fait son
travail alors justement sur cette
question de calendrier Olivier pyon
est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est une
sorte de course contre Laam entre les
les juges d'un côté et les avocats de
Donald Trump de l'autre oui complètement
en tout cas c'est l'un des aspects pour
on va parler d'alternative à Donald
Trump et non plus d'antitrump la la la
la la modification est tout à fait
juste pendant un certain temps en tout
cas durant l'année 2023 on avait
clairement espéré que le calendrier
judiciaire permettrait d'une certaine
manière
de de de rendre Donald Trump comptable
de ses actes avant la primaire et voire
même le cas échéant avant l'élection du
5 novembre il s'avère que ça devient de
plus en plus compliqué ça a été rappelé
le le le procès le procès le plus
important le concernant c'est celui qui
concerne le les lesmeutes du Capitol du
6 janvier il débute le 4 mars la veille
du Super Tuesday qui aura lieu le 5 mars
le début du procès ce qui est
extrêmement tard ce qui est extrêmement
tardif de la même manière la Géorgie
l'autre gros dossier qui lui pose
problème problème comme ça a été
également rappelé c'est le 5 août 2024
que le procès va débuter dans tous les
cas de figure en tant que simple
justifable Donald Trump aura la
possibilité de faire appel il aura même
la possibilité de saisir la Cour suprême
et donc on est sur un temps long
judiciaire qui va forcément sauf
miracle dépasser déborder du calendrier
politique l'un des procureurs Jack Smith
avait demandé à la Cour suprême de
raccourcir les délais justement pour que
Donald Trump soit jugé avant les
échéances
électorales il n'a pas été entendu il y
a également la les dispositions ça n'a
pas été rappelé mais c'est important la
disposition de la Cour suprême du
Colorado qui souhaite interdire à Donald
Trump de pouvoir figurer dans la
primaire euh dans le Colorado la
décision de la Cour suprême sera rendue
le 8 février il y a très peu de chance
que la Cour suprême suive la Cour
suprême du Colorado tout simplement
parce que les droits de la défense vont
doivent être respectés et on ne peut
peut pas empêcher on ne peut pas
sanctionner quelqu'un qui n'a pas été
condamné on ne peut pas condamner
quelqu'un qui n'a pas été jugé et encore
une fois le procès du Capitol début le 4
mars donc oui effectivement pour
répondre à votre question il est
pratiquement illusoire on va être
prudent mais il est très illusoire de
penser que la litanie des affaires
judiciaires puisse empêcher Donald Trump
d'aller au terme s'il est qualifié
évidemment d'aller au terme de cette
élection et dernier point rapide le
début des faire le début du dossier Jud
des des dossiers judiciaires le
concernant date de mars 2023 en mars
2023 dans les sondages il était derrière
run the STI c'est à partir du moment où
la litanie des affaires a commencé à
faire l'actualité qu'il a commencé qu'il
a véritablement décollé dans les
sondages et qu'il a pris de plus en plus
d'avance sur ses principaux concurrents
donc là le lien de corrélation il est
clair il est victimisé et il en profite
à plein ce qui peut sembler totalement
étonnant vu d'ici si on prend
effectivement le la question de
l'insurrection la attaque du du
Capitol regardez ce ce sondage est-ce
que un procès pourrait faire changer
d'avis ces Américains un quart des
Américains et 44 % des électeurs de
Trump qui pensent que le FBI est à
l'origine de ces attaques du Capitol
elisachelle ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que dans cette campagne il y a une
bataille que Trump a a déjà gagné
peut-être même depuis plusieurs années
c'est celle des vérités vérités
alternatives ces américains dont on
parle là ils sont quoi ils sont dans une
bulle un peu un peu délirante alors il
faut prendre en compte aussi la
temporalité de la campagne les études de
sciences politiques américaines ont
montré que les électeurs qui se mobilise
le plus tôt dans la campagne notamment
ceux qui répondent au sondage sont les
électeurs les plus radicaux donc il faut
quand même avoir en tête cette dimension
de temporalité à mesure qu'on va
s'avancer dans le calendrier de ces
élections avec une nomination probable
de Donald Trump comme candidat
républicain un vote antirtrump peut
aussi se cristalliser mais à la proche
de la menace donc le fait qu'il y ait
des électeurs radicalisés parmi la base
de d'afficionados de de Trump au fond
c'est c'est c'est un peu c'est un peu à
donner c'est c'est pas nouveau mais vous
n dites que les autres se mobiliseront
plus tard c'est c'est ça d'une certaine
façon exactement c'estàd les électeurs
les plus modérés qui pourraient dont on
parlait tout à l'heure qui pourrait
prendre peur face à un possible retour
de Trump se mobiliseront mais plus tard
et suite aux États-Unis on a un crédit
beaucoup plus important aux théories
conspirationnistes chose qu'on voit pas
forcément depuis la France mais les les
théories conspirationnistes se
développent beaucoup plus avec un crédit
beaucoup plus important qui l'aurait
accordé je dirais de manière culturelle
donc je pense qu'il faut prendre ces
affirmations au sérieux mais aussi les
les relativiser au vu de la campagne
électorale et de la culture américaine
je voudrais pas donner le sentiment
d'avoir un peu d'arrogance dans la façon
de de de de traiter cette information là
mais c'est tellement enfin bon 44 % des
électeurs de Trump qui pensent que le
FBI estta à l'origine de l'attaque du
Capitol comment vous l'expliquez je
commence avec vous Alexis Pichard et
ensuiteine Bujon comment j'explique tout
simplement parce que la la plupart
peut-être pas les 44 % en question mais
ah si 44 % des électeurs de Trump si
parce que comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure c'est c'est Trump c'est un
gourou c'est il est il est à la tête
d'une secte et Trump n'a cessé de dire
depuis 2020 qui qu'on lui avait voler
l'élection et si on fait si on consulte
les sondages parmi ces électeurs une
large majorité pense que c'est le cas
que Biden a volé la rétion de de de
Donald Trump et dans dans dans le siège
de de mais quand on est à ce niveau
pardon interrompe 44 % ça veut dire
qu'il il y a des gens de toutes origines
il y a des gens instruits il y a des
gens qui ont fait enfin voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est c'est c'est pas le
chiffre le plus inquiétant c'est plutôt
25 % des américain amériain non mais je
suis d'accord avec vous mais c'est ça
revient au même quoi c'est bon c'est
quoi c'est on est dans ce que vous
décriviez c'està dire c'est c'est c'est
c'est bulles cognitiv ça nous arrive
aussi à nous dans lequel on est enfermé
on finit par n'avoir que les
informations qu'on a envie d'entendre
j'aurais envie de vous répondre euh de
façon peut-être un peu provocatrice à
votre première question oui il a gagné
la bataille des vérités alternative oui
il ment il raconte n'importe quoi depuis
6 ans et on et et on ne lui en tient
absolument pas rigueur et hier après
l'owa il a dit c'est la troisème fois
consécutive que nous remportons la
victoire dans l'aiowa c'est faux il a
alors il a gagné la dernière fois mais
la fois d'avant il avait perdu euh
contre un candidat plus évangélique donc
oui il a gagné cette bataille alors
ensuite si vous voulez ce qui est très
difficile avec cette question de la
théorie du complot et vous dites
vous-même je voudrais pas avoir l'air
arrogant comment peuvent-ils croire une
chose pareil euh le problème c'est que
quand Donald Trump parle de l'État
profond de il y a des éléments qui
peuvent lui donner raison je regardais
sur ces procès il dit je suis victime
euh d'élite corrompu euh et d'une
justice politisée alors c'est vrai que
la justice est politisée aux États-Unis
c'est absolument vrai donc en faut
expliquer les juges sont é ça V dans ce
mais qui sont pas là où il raconte mais
donc oui la justice aux États-Unis est
très politique oui Bill Clinton a été
victime d'ennui judiciaire qui était
entièrement drivé par la politique donc
voyez il déplace un tout petit peu le
curseur et en fait il il donne une voix
il donne une expression à ce que
ressentent beaucoup d'électeurs
américains aujourd'hui qui est qu' ne
sont pas bien
représentés par les hommes et femmes
politique au congrès à la Cour Suprême
ou ailleurs mais est-ce que à contrario
ces résultats là qui nous qui nous
stupéfient ou le succès de Donald Trump
sont pas aussi le fait d'une immense
défaite politique des démocrates en
général et de Biden en particulier ça
fait 4 ans qu'ils sont au pouvoir et ils
n'ont pas su soit alors c'est pas simple
he imposer un contrediscours ou mener
une politique qui
désamorce ce phénomène ou qui ou qui
arrive en réalité l'état des forces
politiques il est à peu près le même qu'
a 4 ansin vous avez un pays qui est très
nettement divisé entre deux blocs et qui
n'arrivve plus à se parler que tout
sépare suivant les endroits où on habite
aux États-Unis et le le président Biden
peut s'en orgueillir d'un certain nombre
de réussit mais vous voyez ce qui compte
c'est la perception des gens par exemple
les résultats économiques sont très bons
mais les Américains sont persuadés enfin
un certain nombre que leur économie va
mal donc en fait Trump parle au
ressentis des gens euh et c'est et c'est
ça sa force politique c'est de donner
une voix à des gens qui se sentent
déclassés qui ont l'impression que tout
va à volo que l'Amérique décline et C
alors vous n parliez de de du côté
gourou ou Messi effectivement Donald
Trump relaye par exemple cette vidéo on
en regarde un
[Musique]
extrait le 14 juin 1946 Dieu a regardé
son paradis et s'est dit j'ai besoin
d'un gardien alors Dieu nous a donné
Trump Dieu a dit j'ai besoin d'un homme
qui se lève avant l'aube qui répare le
pays qui travaille tout le jour qui
combat les marxistes et reste dans le
bureau aprèsminuit avec les chefs d'État
donc Dieu créa
Trump je vous avoue quelque chose quand
j'ai vu ce pour la première fois j'ai
cru que c'était un sketch j'ai cru que
c'était un sketch du du Saturday Night
Live l'émission phare très drôle de de
NBC mais non c'est pas un sketch ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il y a une
partie de l'électorat chrétien
évangélique dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure qui qui veut croire ça euh oui
et moi ça me rappelle aussi une
déclaration de George Bush donc
président républicain entre 2000 et 2009
euh qui avait dit moi je me suis
réveillé un jour et Dieu m'a parlé et il
fallait que je devienne président donc
il y a il y a effectivement ce contexte
religieux chez ces deux présidents euh
mais effectivement moi ça évoque aussi
les les théories complotistes de qenon
hein qenon qui est ce groupe d'extrême
droite qui croit en un en un complot
pédosataniste qui serait entretenu par
les les démocrates et dont euh et et
Donald Trump serait la figure qui
viendrait pour fendre justement ce
complot et donc il est il se place en
position de Messi auprès de ses
électeurs qui sont un peu ses oes qui
lui sont acquis à un point d'un point de
vue qui est métaphysique qui dépasse
vraiment la la la rationalité etach
votre avis là-dessus parce
que on peut pas dire que Donald Trump
incarne parfaitement les valeurs
chrétiennes donc ceux qui le soutiennent
ils le font par quoi par intérêt bien
compris par cynisme alors depuis les
années 70 les évangéliques se sont
politisés du côté des républicains donc
on a une politisation d'une droite
religieuse depuis les années 70 aux
États-Unis et effectivement Donald Trump
n'incarne pas par son parcours personnel
et son style les valeurs conservatrices
donc pour continuer de parler à cette
électorat il doit emprunter des styles
de communication politique qui nous
paraissent étranges mais parce que nous
sommes français et que nous vivons dans
une République laïque oui aux États-Unis
le président prête serment sur la Bible
exactement et on se souvient que
pendant que ces dernières années Donald
Trump avait aussi posé devant une église
avec une bible donc il doit convaincre
de ce style messianique c'est la
communication politique qui est adapté à
un pays qui est beaucoup plus religieux
que nous le sommes en France donc il
s'il le fait c'est qu'il y a un intérêt
ce n'est pas pour amuser la la galerie
du tout c'est que ça a un effet et qu'il
a une partie de l'électorat religieux et
donc républicain ouis qui cro la fin
monde qui cro l'ement d'un nouveau
Messie et et qui est dans ce type de
croyance religieuse mais c'est même
purittin ne lu reproche pas son son son
comportement avec les femmes ça compense
et si je peux me permettre non mais
est-ce qu'il y a un intérêt est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y a un retour sur
investissement pour les pour les
chrétiens évangéliques lors du premier
mandat Donald Trump là encore je crois
qu'il faut nuancer beaucoup de il y a
une droite chrétienne aux États-Unis qui
s'est beaucoup politisé aujourd'hui elle
est aussi catholique dans les juges
conserv de la Cour suprême il y a aussi
des catholiques voilà il faut faire
attention les choses évoluent par
ailleurs les États-Unis sont aussi en
voie de sécularisation et quand on parle
de qanon Don dont effectivement Donald
Trump et le Messi c'est pas la même
chose que les évangéliques non plus donc
il peut y avoir du du du
conspirationnisme du messianisme dans
tous ces courants différents mais c'est
c'est quand même pas exactement la même
chose il y a un élément qui qui boucle
avec ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur
les procès c'est queil y avait un Pact
entre la droite chrétienne et Donald
Trump c'était qu'il se débrouille pour
faire nommer un maximum de juges
fédéraux et au niveau des États-Unis
donc fédéux fédéré un maximum de juges
très conservateurs et là il a
complètement tenu sa partie du deal lui
qui est le roi du deal
et exactement précisément donc en un
sens ce qu'il voulait de Donald Trump
ces électeurs là ils l'ont obtenu
effectivement allez on fait un focus sur
euh parce que c'est une autre façon de
de de comprendre Donald Trump ses
relations avec Emmanuel Macron Mathieu
oui parce que on le sait les relations
entre les deux hommes ont étit plutôt en
DCI des haut des bas plutôt de plutôt de
bas que de haut ça avait pourtant
commencé comme une bromance vous vous
souvenez avec ses poignet de mains hyper
viril pour ce jaoger qui serait le plus
fort ça c'était vite gâté avec le make
our planet great again vous savez après
que Donald Trump ait pris la décision de
sortirer des des accord de Paris cette
espèce de message posté par Emmanuel
Macron cette adresse aux américains qui
voulaient venir chez nous je sais pense
sil y en a eu beaucoup puis il y avait
eu un dîner de rabiage au second étage
de la tour effff dans le restaurant
julvert entre couple avec l'invitation
de Donald Trump au défi du 14 juillet
bref voilà des débuts compliqués puis de
nouvelles brouill quand même de plus en
plus notamment à propos de la taxation
des géants du numérique que défendait la
France et à laquelle s'opposait
Washington un épisode qui a donné lieu
aujourd'hui un véritable sketch du
candidat Trump regardez c'était il y a
un peu plus d'une semaine lun meting
avant le Cuse
de the head of France you know Macron
you know Macron he's a very nice guy
Macron and uh really very nice guy I
said Emanuel how are you he said fine I
said I heard you're going to charge
American companies 25% to do things in
nexxico already passed I said well you
better unpass it because if you don't
unpass it you're going to pay a 100% TFF
on all wines and champages that are
shipped into the United States starting
tonight
[Applaudissements]
voilà faire
passer une pouleouill car traditionnelle
des Françis ça pas forcémentéchauffer
les relations entre hommes alors comment
le président français réagit face à
cette hypothèse d'un retour Donald Trump
à la maison ben la question lui a été
posée hier soir hein lors de sa
conférence de presse on a une réponse au
début toute diplomatique hein je PRS je
prends les dirigeants que les peuples me
donne dit Emmanuel Macron avant de
détailler les résultats qu'il avait pu
avoir avec Donald Trump lorsque celui-ci
était à Washington notamment sur il a
cité une opération militaire en Syrie
hein vous souvenez l'opération Hamilton
mais aussi en évoquant les échecs hein
sur le climat notamment ou sur certaines
taxations comme une réponse au sketch de
l'ayowa en fait Emmanuel Macron ne le
dira pas comme ça même s'il fait parfois
allusion euh le trumpisme pour lui il
lui sert de repoussoir absolu euh vous
vous souvenez euh c'est parfois même
bien commode l'an dernier euh pendant
les manifestations d'opposition à la
réforme des retraites il cite le Capitol
euh dans dans son interview euh à la
télévision euh hier il a aussi parler de
justement des fake news quand il parlait
des écrans des portables en voyant on
voit bien ce que ça peut donner ailleurs
euh donc on voit bien euh la la la la
que le le trumpisme lui sert de
repoussoir d'une certaine façon mais il
l'a dit aussi hier j'ai trouvé ça assez
intéressant quel quel que soit le
résultat de l'élection en novembre
prochain il s'attend plus à rien il a
dit alors là pour de C des termes un peu
moins diplomatiqu en expliquant que les
États-Unis était une démocratie en crise
dont la priorité était elle-même et dont
la deuxième priorité était la question
chinoise en disant en gros B de toute
façon quel que soit le résultat je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il que nous les
concernions encore enfin qu'ils soi
encore intéressés par ce qu'on fait et
appelant du coup les Européens à être
lucide sur ce point et à faire bloc
merci beaucoup Mathieu laine Bujon
est-ce que ça changerait vraimentond
famentalement les relations France USA
une victoire de Donald Trump oui je je
pour moi si vous voulez sans
contexte une deuxème élection Donald
Trump aurait un certain nombre de
conséquences imprévisibles mais
globalement assez désastreuse sur le
contexte géopolitique mondial que je
seulement sur les relations Fran voilà
ce que je dirais pas du tout de de Joe
Biden mais imaginez la crise qu'on vit
en ce moment au Moyen-Orient avec Donald
Trump à la Maison Blanche et ça donne
une idée alors ensuite je pense qu'il y
a une évolution de fond des relations
transatlantiques qui est effectivement
pour la France et pour l'Europe de
manière plus large de comprendre que
elle s'éloigne si vous voulez des
États-Unis qui défendent leurs propres
intérêts qui se tournent plus vers
l'Asie comme on le sait pour lesquels
l'Europe n'est plus le centre du monde
quoi que l'Ukraine est un peu rebattu
ces cartesl aussi cette évolution
structurelle de fond elle ne dépend pas
des présidents et on pourrait dire qu'il
y a beaucoup de continuité dans les
politiques étrangères aussi de Obama
puis Trump puis Biden mais ensuite entre
les deux hommes il y a un style très
différent et Joe Biden ne cesse de
rappeler l'importance des alliances
historique militaire et politique des
États-Unis c'est quelqu'un qui tient
beaucoup à l'OTAN par exemple alors que
vous savez que Donald Trump a dit qu'il
voulait sortir de l'OTAN ou qu'il
pourrait sortir de l'OTAN ce qui pose
quand même dans ce cas-là un certain
nombre
urgent à la France et à l'Europe pour le
coup à une époque où Emmanuel Macron
jugait l'OTAN en état de mort cérébrale
oui c'était évidemment avant l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie Olivier pyon
lors du premier mandat de Donald Trump
on l'a su pendant et puis après il y
avait un certain nombre de gardefous qui
s'était mis en place et et notamment à
l'intérieur même de de de la Maison
Blanche est-ce que ça pourra fonctionner
de nouveau ou est-ce qu'il y a un risque
que finalement Donald Trump euh prennent
encore plus ses aises si j'ose dire s'il
est réélu
euh moi j'ai j'ai assisté aux deux aux
deux visites d'État de d'Emmanuel Macron
à Washington et la première en 2018
était avec Donald Trump et on se
souvient tous de ce moment assez
surréaliste où Donald Trump époussè
comme ça le le le veston de de de
d'Emmanuel Macron comme une sorte de jeu
entre deux grands singes avec le singe
dominant et le singe soi-disant dominé
Donald Trump a toujours fondé euh c'est
pas pour faire de la de la psychologie
de de de primate mais il y a quand même
un peu de ça c'est-à-dire qu'on est
quand même toujours avec lui dans le cas
de l'Alpha mal du grand singe qui veut
absolument démontrer qu'il est dominant
et la sortie qu'il a fait il y a
quelques jours effectivement concernant
concernant le le l'épisode de
l'augmentation des des taxes et
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses
complètement fausse tout est faux dans
cette histoire c'était pas 25 % c'était
5 % et on n pas du tout renoncé à la
taxation donc en plus on est dans de la
fake new absolument complète est-ce que
ça changera quelque chose en cas de
réélection probablement pas est-ce que
ça s'empirera il faut être prudent mais
euh si vous voulez la seule bonne
nouvelle en tout cas pour l'Europe et
pour la France que l'on pourrait voir en
cas de réélection Donald Trump c'est
effectivement ce qui a été dit c'est une
sorte d'exigence de de de
d'autonomisation de la part de l'Europe
et de la France c'estàdire de moins
compter sur le parapluie le soutien ti
l'accompagnement américain et de prendre
un petit peu plus nos nos nos
responsabilités sur le l'état
relationnel que l'on peut espérer entre
Donald Trump et n'importe quel dirigeant
notamment européen que ce soit on l'avit
v avec Angela Merkel ou au Canada avec
Justin Trudeau ça sera toujours dans le
mode toxique c'est ce sera toujours à la
fois il est très sympathique il est très
sympa mais en même temps je le black
Bull quand j'en ai envie parce que c'est
quand même moi le patron et donc
l'obligation d'essayer derrière de
fonder une stratégie ou une nouvelle
diplomatie qui prenne ceci en compte
beaucoup plus que lors du premier mandat
si éventuellement il y en avait un
deuxième et l'obligation pour les
Européens de s'estimer comme étant d'une
certaine manière libéré en tout cas
moins comptable de l'influence
américaine est à mon avis absolument
indispensable et d'ailleurs des
réflexions sont actuellement menées sur
ce point dans le cas de la réélection de
Donald Trump tout simplement pour ne pas
revivre ces espèces de de d'épisodes de
relation toxiques et donc
diplomatiquement de relation difficilees
entre les États-Unis et ses alliés
européens merci beaucoup merci Olivier
piton merci à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat j'ai rappelé Olivier pyon Le le
titre de votre livre consacré à la
vice-présidente camala Haris la
pionnière de l'Amérique livre publié aux
éditions plomb à bientôt à très bientôt
sur sur le plateau de de Public Sénat
notez que demain l'invité de la matinale
avec Oriane mansini sera Thierry Breton
le commissaire européen au Marché
intérieur belle soirée à toutes et à à
demain 18h et
[Musique]
22h